grand theft auto 3 a revolutionary game
with one of the first truly open cities
players could explore at their whim
despite being a huge gamer growing up
i never owned the game or truly played
its story
but 20 years later i figured it was time
to finally delve into the trilogy and
fill in my gaming knowledge gap and see
how these milestones in video game
history hold up so i finally picked up
gta 3 with the trilogy's definitive
edition
it's definitive nothing could go wrong
right
[Music]
oh no
oh no
oh [ __ ] here we go again
okay i honestly didn't plan on the
definitive edition being a hot coffee
mess but that's what i got and that's
what a first-time solo player like
myself gets to tell you about today i
decided to start playing out of order
with vice city because i'm a badass law
breaking thug who breaks all the rules
also because i always love this 80s
retro wave aesthetics and that is one
thing that stood out to me while playing
the game on my ps5 and i mean that
specifically because i played the game
on both my switch and ps5 and the switch
version is total crap but oh don't you
worry we'll get into that the
environments of vice city are at times
gorgeous to look at on the ps5 i love
the pink and blue hues that come in
during sunset and it makes driving
around the city all that much better in
fact vice city was a prime example of
showing off just how powerful my new ps5
was this baby was running on overdrive
processing all the polygons
the character models during the intro
walked like completely normal human
beings
the realism and proportions of the npcs
truly unmatched for a graphical upgrade
i found this bikini clad girl on the
streets of vice city only to turn around
run to the end of the block and see her
twin within draw distance of her sexiest
gta of all time
sexy this dude like i i can't i can't
keep up with this charade what is this
mess
definitive
okay so the graphical upgrade is not
great beyond some of the environments in
fact while i downloaded this game on day
one for the ps5 there was a patch
available a couple weeks later and
instead of fixing the game the 20 year
old game now stuttered and i had to
switch on performance mode to play the
game without dropped frames a game on my
ps5 that looks like this
now you're playing with power
and on the switch the game is even worse
in docked mode the switch will stutter
every time you drive
no matter what and this is what an
explosion looks like in vice city uncut
and with no editing
okay
graphics aside how does the gameplay
hold up for someone like myself who
decide to play a famous game far beyond
its prime
well while it feels dated it's not in a
bad way the gameplay is still fun and
honestly some of the wonkiness of early
3d is hilarious in a good way while the
spectacle of an open city you can freely
explore isn't what it was before as many
games now incorporate this to a grander
scale i still appreciate this and shanmu
are where it came from and this
particular playground is still fun to
explore with driving around learning
every avenue for a quick getaway being a
blast it's not overwhelming and i think
that's something that's often overlooked
in absolutely massive open world games
when a game is too big it can sometimes
lose focus with many things existing
just for the sake of making the game
bigger
without a genuine gameplay reason the
physics of the vehicles feel absolutely
wonky at times but in a way it also
makes them feel arcady thanks to their
physics which again isn't a bad thing i
mean sure sometimes i would spin in an
insane way but it all really just
cracked me up the mission structure of
the game is simple with a number of
short missions you can complete
relatively quickly again it's honestly
nice to go back to something a little
more simple where missions involve you
needing to catch invincible pizza
delivery boys who deliver pizzas by
tossing them onto the ground
i'm just saying i hit him with my car
off of his scooter multiple times and
shot him yet he still will not die
is he actually a pizza delivery god the
pizza god himself
[Music]
while the gameplay is still fun the
dialogue
well let's just say it's no red dead
redemption 2.
there's a lot of dick in this game and
i'm going to mail you the dicks of those
responses when the giant shark comes in
and just bites their dicks off what i
have now is heads stick everywhere yo
the writing is more juvenile which is
fine but it definitely makes the game
feel dated
sally though as much as i enjoyed
meeting sylvester stallone and hanging
out with the most attractive girl i've
ever seen in my life
that's how elbows work right it was time
to move on to gta 3 colon
just gta 3 because i have deadlines i
have to meet now this this was truly the
game that started it all the game that
was so violent it caused absolute
outrage and today
it feels kind of quaint
sure i could attack anybody in any way
and steal people's cars but it wasn't
overly gory and actually pretty cartoony
overall i give it a 3 out of 10
offensive rating
on the offensive meter
with the one being super mario brothers
and a 10 being the zelda cdi games
but history aside time to immerse myself
in gta 3. one thing you'll quickly learn
in gta 3 is the importance of getting
paint jobs on cars you learn this
through your first boss luigi who has
you murder someone he doesn't like and
then change the color of his car to
teach him a lesson yeah i'm sure his
ghost is looking down like
what what the f
that was my car it's supposed to be blue
i i hate red okay yes i realized the
point was to steal the car and changing
the color makes it harder to find and
therefore easier to steal
but i like this narrative in fact if you
have a giant wanted level and cops are
right on your tail chasing you by
getting your car painted right in front
of them suddenly they have no idea who
you are anymore video game logic at its
finest
oh sorry it's still dave talking to you
i can understand why i was confusing
being that i'm wearing different clothes
and all
honestly going back and playing the
original gta 3 is
um
it's okay while i appreciate the history
of it the writing is a notch down from
vice city the dialogue and cutscenes
feel like they're trying way too hard to
be edgy just like how the humor in my
videos is very try hard
it hurts because it's true
and more importantly to me vice city was
the game that introduced riding
motorcycles and i really
really miss that again there's some odd
quirks i'm not sure if our part of the
original game or were botched on the
port the horrifying npcs like this lady
who walks like no human i've ever seen
and how did they approve this npc for
the final release or this guy with a
different mustache hair color from his
normal hair color those were definitely
not in the original game also while this
was a minor issue in vice city the rain
in the original gta 3 is more like a
torrential downpour every single time it
rains this also wasn't an issue in the
original game
but other things i wasn't so sure about
like while i was doing the mission drive
misty for me the ice cream truck was
non-stop playing over the mission
briefing audio the don's son joey leone
he wants some action from his regular
girl misty during firefights the lock-on
of these games are absolutely garbage
and i mean it when i say they're
terrible half of the time the game will
lock onto a random npc instead of who
you're aiming for and as it turns out
that terrible aiming is specific to the
definitive edition the originals had far
better aiming mechanics and i actually
had to manually switch back to the
original controls
even though this was my first time truly
experiencing the game
at the end of the day while gta 3
definitely feels the most dated within
this trilogy it's still nice to see just
how much fun the developers seem to have
with the game from hidden nooks and
crannies to random posters spoofing on
films like this bad fellas poster or the
fact you can do things like stealing an
ice cream truck even though the missions
are basically either you driving
somewhere or shooting somebody they
really tried to vary up how you'd have
to do these activities and i really
could tell how this became a classic
back when it first came out and really a
lot of it was about the games you could
create for yourself hey girls you want a
wild time
[Music]
honestly though i didn't spend too much
time playing the original gta 3. i
decided to instead focus most of my time
on playing the most popular gta game and
one that i'd actually never played
before
san andreas
and right at the start we're introduced
to a new mechanic bicycles also
literally on my first mission to go home
yep this is the definitive edition
alright something i somewhat knew but
still pleasantly enjoyed were all of the
new mechanics brought to san andreas and
i'm not just talking about new vehicles
there's a much more customization to
your character which adds more incentive
to play the game you'll be able to
actually upgrade your skill at driving
various types of vehicles as well as
your general stats
and honestly i'm an absolute sucker for
rpg mechanics like these so i was all in
on top of that now you can customize
your digs get haircuts and even gain
weight by eating too much food now this
is the gangster life
grove street sun
and speaking of grove street there's now
gang warfare where you can take over
turf multiple cities and the ability to
date girls who have their own
relationship stats and oh my god what
did they do to your face
well
time to impress her
i guess handsome status zero
what
good thing the game has another new
feature working out to gain muscle and
lose weight
oh and as this is the definitive edition
don't you worry
i found a barrage of bugs i especially
appreciate that in the very first
emotion-filled cutscene finding out your
mom is dead carl's hands look like
baseball mitts
this piece of guy whose bottom lip goes
up instead of down when he talks enjoy
sir
this guy who had a magical floating
blunt shootouts where enemies seem to
forget they were dead
this supersonic car
that also caused a bunch of accidents
i went into this club where floating
people were dancing to no music
i'm not cutting the audio of this
gameplay there's just no music
stealth killing enemies uh
like this
sure
this car that attached to me like a
magnet
i'm not joking i'm going to fast forward
the footage so you can see
this mission where cj's neck was stuck
inside the car seat this rolling blob
that turned into a cop
or this other cop who decided to pop
down from the ceiling and float inside
of it shooting at me upside down
or even falling through the ground
while all of this is hilarious and most
of these things probably weren't in the
original game
there are some things that honestly
don't hold up too well today for example
the game has a number of ddr style
missions and they just feel out of place
and aren't particularly enjoyable
yes they're mini games but it just made
me wish i was playing guitar man instead
[Music]
meanwhile some of the races are poorly
conceived and it's not because racing is
a bad idea it's actually a really good
idea in a game that involves you
constantly driving around it's more so
that some of the races are pretty long
and you have no idea what the course is
you only get to see one marker at a time
with an indicator showing a vague
direction of where to go next all the
game would have needed was a second
yellow marker and this issue would have
been solved also it needs to be said
zero's rc plane mission is an absolute
nightmare the controls are horrendous i
consider myself to be a pretty good
gamer so it was actually a huge relief
when i looked online and found out that
there's actually a common consensus
about this one
zero can get [ __ ] the car ai is
oftentimes awful and while it can be
hilarious like in the instance of when i
finish this mission right here
[Music]
typically the car ai is notably dated
and is the reason why i'll never trust
fully automated cars
[Music]
the point about the cars isn't
necessarily a negative as i actually
kind of like how wonky the car ai is the
point is that the ai itself feels kind
of dated similarly it's kind of funny to
see absolutely no consequence for a
mission where you basically murder an
entire army of national guard soldiers
or entire army of police in swat
and the fact that chugging sodas is a
good way to replenish your health
on top of the gameplay the game's humor
also feels a little dated pretty much
every single cop joke in this game aside
from them being corrupt is that they
love donuts and while i honestly don't
care it's just the type of humor that 13
year old me would probably find
hilarious but 34 year old me just has a
different sense of humor now but you
know what playing gta san andreas for
the first time i do understand where the
love comes from exploring san andreas
santa fierro and
i didn't have time to get to the las
vegas section before writing this video
all have a unique charm to them and san
andreas is definitely the best of the
three games in terms of gameplay
for aesthetics i'll always hold a soft
spot for vice city but i definitely love
the mishmash of missions in san andreas
the wild and weird characters the feel
of each city all of the vehicles and
ways to play in the sandbox of san
andreas and of course the rpg mechanics
honestly it was a good time even though
i was playing the definitive editions
obviously that's not the best way to
play these games but you know what it
honestly made for a memorable first true
play through these games in its own way
i feel like playing all of this gta 3
has transformed me in fact i think it's
time to take what i learned from playing
the gta trilogy into the real world like
every parent's worst nightmare
now i too was grove street for life
if you don't serve their dicks on a
platter for me i'm going to cut off all
your dicks sew them into a dick purse
that holds other dicks inside of it
capisce
dave um
i
i think this is an hr conversation not
um
get me those dicks
okay
all right
hey i hope you enjoyed this video if so
i made another similar video playing
cyberpunk 7 months after its release to
see how it played after a number of
patches i hope you'll check it out
[Music]
you